[Music]
well hey you guys happy Christmas Eve
hopefully you're having a good one so
far um mine's been pretty lowkey we
slept late uh had some butter chicken
that's about it I'm kind of getting in
the spirit though I got me some uh got a
little double Mocha Cappuccino there
with some little candy cane sticking out
of it so you know that's kind of
Christmasy I guess might break out the
booze a little bit later but it's kind
of early now so yeah so just as I
promised um I was going to do one more
Christmas horror movie before actual
Christmas day now this one uh was
recommended by Danny and it's actually
on shutter as of this stream which is
you know obviously Christmas Eve 20123
so if you want to check it out it's over
there so this is another killer Santa
movie now you know obviously killer
Santa movies kind of a dime a dozen
really there's a whole bunch of them um
matter of fact I just talked about a new
one like from 2022 just a couple of days
ago which was called Christmas Bloody
Christmas directed by Joe beos which is
actually pretty good that's also on
shutter if you want to check that out
but but the one we're talking about
today from
1980 um to all a good night this
actually has a few things that
distinguish it from all the other ones
right so for one thing this is kind of
an interesting bit of trivia um it was
actually not only the first slasher
movie released in the 1980s um it
actually got I believe a limited
theatrical release in January of 1980
obviously it was supposed to come out
before Christmas but there was uh
conflicts with the production company it
didn't work out so it came out in
January um but so it was the first Lash
movie that released in the ' 80s and it
was also in fact the first horror movie
released in the 1980s uh full stop I
will say that shortly after it was
released um it seemed to Fall Into
Obscurity pretty quickly I don't even
think it got a VHS release until 1983 so
several years later it was also uh as
far as I'm aware the sole uh director's
credit of actor and musician David hes
who horror fans will obviously know best
as Krug from West Craven's Last House on
the Left from
1972 hey Dave what's going on uh yeah
Merry Christmas to you I'm just sitting
here having my having a capucina with
some with peever stick in it and talking
about talking about a Christmas slasher
movie as as one does as one does so yeah
so Krug himself directed this movie he
was I feel like he was better known as
an actor but I think this was his only
and a musician too but I think this was
the only movie that he ever uh
directed um there's also a bunch of
other fun trivia about this which a
little bit more obscure but I found this
entertaining anyway now how about this
this movie was also actually one of only
a few screenwriting credits by a dude
named Alex Rebar who also played the
title character in The Awful yet somehow
still awesome nice 1977 movie The
Incredible melting man which was on MST
and it's a really good episode like it's
a ridiculous movie though I don't really
know what the it's what it's baffling
just seriously watch it uh the movie
this movie also has um a main character
who's played by someone and it kept
bugging me the whole time and then
finally I had to look up look it up
who's played by Jennifer ran she
actually had a small part in
Ghostbusters from 1984 she was one of
the you know like at the very beginning
when Bill Murray has those two students
that he's like you know given the xener
cards or whatever like trying to test if
they're psychic and he's like keeps
shocking the guy but like the cute girl
he's just like oh my God you keep
guessing them right but obviously she's
guessing them wrong that's her that's
Jennifer Ran So she has like a main part
in this one so I thought that was kind
of funny because I was like oh yeah the
girl from Ghostbusters uh she W she also
had a leading role um on the first
season of Charles in Charge that's
that's 8 sitcom was Scott Mayo so
there's that too um oh and if all of
that wasn't enough I found this quite
fascinating if you're really paying
attention you might spot porn star Harry
Reams who was in deep throat and he was
in the devil and Miss Jones kind of the
big uh the two big um other than I guess
Behind the Green Door or whatever the
hell um but those were kind of the two
of like the Golden Age of porn like back
in the 70s so yeah so he's in this but
he's credited as Dan
Striker um and he's only in it for like
a couple of minutes he plays like this
tiny part as like an airplane pilot who
eventually gets chopped up by a
propeller so there's that but he's
definitely in it so after all of that
after this Litany of fascinating facts
about this movie is this any good is it
like a lost Christmas horror gem or
something I don't know if I'd say that
um it kind of like depends on your point
of view I guess because you know and how
also how tolerant you are of kind of not
great slasher movies you know what I
mean now it's entertaining in places for
sure um but I feel like that's mostly in
a I don't know if I'd go so far as to
say it's like so bad it's good but there
are definite aspects of like what the
[__] did I just watch to this you know
what I mean um just in general like the
acting is generally kind of poor um the
dialogue is kind of repetitive some of
it's real cringy um and sometimes like
barely coherent like doesn't make any
sense The Kills aren't really all that
gory um the plot doesn't make a whole
lot of sense like it has a lot of plot
holes in it and there are some kind of
like boring kind of protracted scenes
even though the movie is only like 87
minutes long right so and I'm going to
say too that the setting of it and the
story of It kind of pretty blatantly
rips off black Christmas from
1974 and here's another weird thing
about it it also would be accused of
ripping off Friday the 13th pretty
however this movie actually came out 4
months before the first Friday the 13th
which actually kind of blows my mind a
little bit and as I kind of go on and
talk about the movie you'll probably
like see why that is like why it's so
weird that there's cuz there's like a
lot of similarities and I'm not really
sure how that happened you know what I
mean like and a lot of kind of specific
similarities which I think is very
strange so much like Bob Clark's classic
black Christmas to all a good night is
set over Christmas obviously but it's
not at a sorority house it's actually
like at a finishing school for girls
which is pretty much like in this
context pretty much the same thing right
it's you know a school with a bunch of
girls in it so at the beginning of the
movie you get kind of this you know
flashback scene kind of a prologue type
thing and it's kind of like your
obligatory slasher movie killer Revenge
setup scenario where there's like a
group of young women and it seems to
that they're like ha in a new recruit or
something um they're just kind of
chasing her through the house and one of
the people chasing her is dressed like
Santa and is carrying like what I
presume is a rubber axe you know which
I'm just like oh yeah that storied
College tradition of hazing Somebody by
chasing them around dressed as Santa
with an axe all right yeah I've heard of
that I have not heard of that but yeah
so uh so that's going on um but as it
happens there's a terrible accident and
the new girl kind of stumbles over this
railing which causes a very very obvious
dummy to kind of flop bonelessly to the
floor a couple of stories below so we
all know the rules of slasher movies by
now and to this movie's credit this was
very early in the slasher movie cycle so
this tropes hadn't really been super
established yet but still by now
everybody knows okay well they showed us
this so that means that either that girl
didn't die and she's going to end up
being the killer or it's going to be
like somebody possessed by her ghost or
some [__] like that or it's going to be
a friend or relative of this girl taking
revenge against these careless [__]
who caused her death right I mean that's
just how slashers work everybody knows
that so the movie jumps ahead two years
then and most of the students are going
home for the holidays as they would
except for kind of a handful of young
women who have chosen to stay behind a
thank you so much Dave that's awesome
that's
awesome a little surprise something
something a we love you too we love you
too thank you so much that's awesome I
hope you have a really good Christmas I
think we're going to have a really good
christm man Tom's cooking some stuff and
it smells really good I'm not sure what
it is exactly kind of smells like bread
but I don't know but yeah we're going to
I'm going to find out later but yeah
so um okay so this all of these young
women that stayed behind Okay yeah it's
you know I'm just kind of trying to do
this now so cuz I know a lot of people
are probably not going to watch it live
cuz they're doing you know Christmas Eve
stuff but I was just like well I'll just
kind of get it done and then people can
watch it later if they want to but yeah
you have a good one have a good one yeah
so uh so all these girls that have
stayed behind um so the group of them
consists of you got a girl named ncy
who's kind of like the virginal goody to
shoes right um who might as well have
final girl tattooed acoss Ross her
forehead and then the other four are
these just kind of snotty
interchangeable [__] basically um whose
names are Melody Leia Trisha and
Sam so um I will note that even though
Jennifer ran obviously who plays Nancy
in this movie and was the same girl that
was in Ghostbusters she went on to have
quite a successful career after this
movie um she's also the best actor here
by far and and you know she's gorgeous
like she's cute as button um but I will
note that many of the other actors
appearing in this movie um list this as
their only film credit and without being
too harsh I'm going to say that doesn't
really surprise me all that much that's
all I'm going to say so I mean it's not
the worst acting I've ever seen by a
long stretch but it's um it's not great
it's no one's going to be knocking their
doors down for any Oscars that's all I'm
saying so it turns out that the head of
the school who we never meet or anything
is going to be away for the weekend so
the only person uh Left Behind is the
hous mother who I guess is like also the
cook I don't know exactly what a
housemother type person does maybe she's
the cook too but her name is Mrs Jensen
and she's going to be left in charge of
all these dick hungry ladies now
predictably because they're very excited
that the you know I presumably strict
like owner of the school is going to be
gone so they're like holy [__] we're
going to um drop some sedatives in the
house Mother's drink going to give her
some like War milk and put drugs in
there they're going to rofy her ass so
they can ship in a literal plane load of
boyfriends and know that is not an
exaggeration because one of the dudes
has a private plane and he's going to
fly all the dudes to the school I don't
know where they're flying from if they
mentioned it I don't remember so it's
like yeah they're shipping in the
boyfriends I thought that was very funny
um so yeah so they're going to come
there and have this big weekend of
drinking and screwing and whatever so uh
the promise pack there they eventually
persuade Nancy the goody two shoes girl
you should be the one to give Mrs Jensen
the drugs because you're the only one of
us that she will not suspect of any
Shenanigans which to be fair um that's
probably true now before they put this
little plan into motion there's this
kind of dinner scene uh you know there's
a nice looking stew and some cherry pie
and [__] like that and you get your
standard issue creepy grounds keeper
character who is introduced here now the
character's name probably should be like
red herring McGee or something like that
but his name is actually Ralph and he
spouts pretty much the same like
portense of Doom that crazy Ralph does
in Friday the 13th like you're all going
to die like that kind of [__] and it's
like that similarity was like I was like
wow that is like really specific and so
like it made me wonder if I don't know
is there some kind of like indie film
Espionage going on this isn't the only
similarity but this was the first one
that like really struck me and I was
kind of like what the hell that's crazy
like his name's also Ralph I'm like you
got to be kidding and he's saying like
pretty much the same stuff you know
you're all doomed it's that kind of [__]
you know I don't think he said exactly
that but it was similar you know what I
mean so I thought that was crazy so this
dude Ralph not crazy Ralph from Friday
the 13th but to all a good night Ralph
um he is like
so overthe toop creepy and skey and like
act so inappropriately toward the girls
and toward Nancy in particular that you
can pretty much be 1,000% sure that he
is not the killer because again we all
know how slashers work now in the
kitchen after dinner an Italian woman
whose relationship to the other
characters is never established shows up
like picks at the girls leftovers like
it start eating stuff off their plates
like complains to Mrs Jensen and Ralph
that she's going to need a bypass and
she's like oh I'm dying blah blah blah
like she saw ketching and stuff and then
she gives him a bunch of canoli like
wrapped in
tinfoil this woman is never seen again
and is never mentioned again and I have
no idea who the [__] she is and what she
has to do with the plot I don't know if
she was just somebody's relative or she
like gave some money for the movie and
she's just like I just want to be in it
for a scene and stuff it's never
explained I don't know if they were
trying to set it up as she was like
another possible killer but it's so
clear that she not the killer that I I
don't really know why it was in there
but it I was like that that a weird
little scene that really didn't need to
be in there but yeah it was just like
canoli sounds good that was pretty much
all I got out of that scene I was like
yeah I'd really like some canoli right
now thank you very much so while all of
that is going on over here over there
there is a sixth young woman named
Cynthia who isn't even in the movie long
enough to like have a Wikipedia credit
so I don't even know what the actress's
name is so she gets naked in front of
her bedroom window because she's you
know getting ready to get dressed to go
out and meet her boyfriend Paul who's
like outside on the school grounds
outside though uh Paul gets stabbed by a
killer Santa before she can come out and
then as soon as Cynthia walks out the
house like she walks out the driveway or
something I mean Santa pretty much walks
up to her and just like [__] Shanks
her as well like just stabs her in the
heart or something um now as far as I
can remember neither Cynthia nor Paul is
mentioned again either and I don't even
remember if their bodies turned up later
cuz you know that another Trope in
slashers like somebody the last person
goes around finding all the bodies of
like their dead friends oh my God oh my
God oh my God so that does kind of
happen in this um but I don't even think
those people's bodies turned up so I'm
like well okay I guess nobody likes
theall all that
much so then you have like so Mrs Jensen
you know retires to her room for the
evening with and they give her the
drugged milk now after that the girls
they all they grab a bunch of
flashlights and go out side at what is
supposed to be midnight but is very
clearly late afternoon okay it's clearly
daytime I was like you didn't even have
a filter or nothing I was like
okay like I don't know why they they had
other sh scenes that were shot at night
I don't know why they didn't just shoot
that like two second scene at night I
don't know it's crazy but it was clearly
the daytime so they go out there to meet
this plane that's transporting their you
know penis providing life forms for the
weekend so here they come um now one
kind of amusing gag uh which may or may
not have been intentional I kind of hope
it was is that Harry Reams you know the
pornstar he plays the only guy in the
movie who he's the pilot so he has to
like stay behind with the plane and he
doesn't get laid so he's the only one
that gets laid and I was like oh har I
see what you that's pretty funny I don't
know what they did on purpose but I hope
they did because it's pretty funny so
all the guys that arrive are pretty much
um just as annoying and just as
interchangeable as the girls are so much
so that I couldn't remember which one
was which and then like when they said
when I looked at the Wikipedia page and
I was looking at everyone's names I'm
like wait which one was that I don't
even remember that guy at all but yeah
um so there was this one guy whose name
was either Tom or Blake I think it was
Tom maybe um and he's supposed to be the
funny one because there's always one in
one slasher movie where he's like Oh's
the funny one he's always doing pranks
and stuff and it's just like he's the
one you're like please kill him first oh
my god um but yeah so he was wearing
this kind of goofy shirt
and I think the only other thing that
makes him be the funny one is that the
other characters say he's the funny one
and then at one point he talks like
Dracula for a minute like for no reason
though I think it was supposed to be dra
I'm not really sure who he was supposed
to be talking like but he just kind of
slowed down and like had a weird accent
I'm just like okay I I didn't really
know what that was but yeah so he's
funny um thankfully though he gets offed
pretty quickly pretty early in the movie
um Santa actually bashes his face in
with a rock so that was good so I didn't
have to like put up with his
jokes as if you want to call them that
you know what I mean so yeah um hey
Tammy what's going on hope you're having
a good Christmas Eve so there's also
this kind of buff douchebag named TJ uh
and he seems to be kind of the leader or
whatever you want to call it and he
brought an acoustic guitar along with
him
and sits there in front of the fire and
just sings a couple of these horribly
horribly offkey folk songs that made me
want to run him over with a VW hippie
bus repeatedly so there was that out of
this group like the only sort of likable
man is this kind of nerdy virgin named
Alex who he just all he talks about is
like math and nerd stuff until he gets a
Pity [__] from one of the girls Melody
and then after that he starts talking
about sports and chasing Nancy around
while acting
like Quasimoto King Kong I couldn't
figure out like I was like is he
supposed to be a gorilla or what is he
doing it's like I that's what I mean
it's like that's what I was saying about
how some of the um stuff in here like
some of the dialogue and stuff like I
wasn't really sure what they were going
for like when he was chasing Nancy
around I'm like what are you supposed to
be it's like I don't understand what
you're doing I thought Quasimoto that
was the first thing that popped in my
head but I was like that's so random
that can't be right but yeah so I don't
know that whole [__] thing was so
weird so anyway uh Trisha who the girl
whose only distinction is that she's
British CU she's also kind of [__]
like all the other ones and you know so
she's British and that's about it um she
gets killed when she goes off to the
fridge to get beer for all the other
people and then like I said the funny
guy Tom he gets bumped off too when he
goes to look for he gets his face
bashing with a rock like he gets outside
somehow I don't remember how that
happened happens um none of the others
seem at all alarmed by their friend's
mysterious disappearances um I mean I
guess they figure they just went off
somewhere to bang which you know to be
fair that does happen a lot in this
movie so I guess they're just like okay
well that's what happened I was like all
right fair enough um hilariously Nancy
and one of the other girls clearly see
blood on the floor in front of the
refrigerator from where Trisha got
murdered but neither of them think
anything is wrong like they're just like
oh that grounds keeper Ralph he must
have just cut his hand or something and
left this big [__] pile of blood like
a big puddle of blood on the floor and
they're just like what abs and it's just
like and then Nancy just kind of starts
cleaning it up I'm like this is insane
okay um and also like the killer Santa
they kind of show them burying some of
the Bodies In the Garden like of the
school and it's again like nobody
notices you know what I mean so all
right so meanwhile uh people like pair
off so you got Sam and Blake and they
start porking in the front room like in
front of the fireplace and then Melody
and virgin Alex are go upstairs and
boink um now Nancy who is the lonely
virginal girl and she's wearing this
kind of frumpy robe and she's drinking
milk because of course she's a goodie
two shoes so she doesn't drink beer she
only drinks milk cuz yeah um and she's
kind so she's drinking milk and she's
very wistfully like watching Sam and
Blake [__] like through the window
like she outside and she's like watching
them through the window and I'm like
that's a little weird Okay um but then
like after she turns away the killer
Santa who is actually not a killer Santa
now because now they're wearing a
medieval suit of armor for you know why
not um I don't know how they put that on
by themselves but okay uh so actually
the so the killer medieval Knight shoots
Blake through the mouth with a crossbow
which is kind of similar to something
that happens in Friday the 13th too and
then cut Sam's head off with a sword or
with an axe I can't remember cuz he was
like using an axe later but I don't
remember if he maybe had a sword that
went with the whole night Ensemble but I
was just kind of like how do how did
they get in that night outfit I don't
know weird that's the only time that
that they're in like in a different
outfit okay like I said doesn't make any
sense so the next morning everybody is
still like pretty [__] Blas about all
the missing people so they're just like
eating breakfast and just shooting the
[__] like whatever nothing's been the
matter so Nancy goes into the woods for
some reason like to look for the people
like I don't know why they'd be out
there but okay and then Alex kind of
follows her like he seems to have taken
like yeah he got a p pity [__] from
Melody but he's just like oh nany is
more my speed you know what I mean
because they're both kind of nerds so um
so while Nancy is like running away from
Alex's Tom Foolery because like I said
he was acting like Quasimoto or whatever
the [__] he was doing um she
accidentally stumbles across Ralph's
corpse now Ralph the creepy grounds
keeper he had actually come into her
room through the window the night before
to warn her that something evil was
going on and that she needed to pray and
she was like not alarmed she was like
what the [__] are you doing in here get
out you [__] freak or anything like
that she was just like oh okay this is a
totally normal thing to happen and he
like gives her a Bible and [__] like
that so he's like yeah something really
bad's going which I mean yeah okay fair
play he's right about that but I was
just like um can you like not can't you
just knock on the door like a regular
person and just like climbing in the
[__] window what the hell so you know
I know they were trying to like set it
up like he was the killer but you know
what I mean you know he's not the killer
cuz it's too much just you know reel it
in a little bit if you're trying to do
some red herring [__] so so yeah so
Ralph got murdered so I guess he should
have taken his own advice about praying
because God sure as [__] didn't save his
creepy ass did he so they call the cops
obviously finally someone does something
so the cops come out to the house or
like one cop comes out to the house and
then later on there's a couple cops so
several of the surviving
teenagers I guess they're supposed to be
teenagers they kind of trying to keep
their names out of the investigation so
they don't get in trouble with their
Rich parents because like I said this is
a finishing school so these are like all
rich
people um so the main detective whose
name is palansky but with a y not like
Roman palansky with an i but palansky
with a Y um and I don't think he even
has a first name do they even say what
his first name is I don't think they do
um I mean he just seems like really
appalled by these kids callousness which
you know uh you know he's like a man has
been murdered and blah blah blah and
then like but TJ is all but my
reputation though you know what I mean
it was that kind of [__] so then
palansky gives this really weird speech
about how Ralph had a pretty extensive
criminal record like assault with a
deadly weapon and stuff like that I'm
like and he was working at a girl school
like do you guys not check people's
references or what the [__] is going on
um you know and oh maybe that
contributed to his death maybe he was
trying to like make them not be afraid
cuz he's like oh well he was a criminal
so he probably just got bumped off
because of his criminal activities but
I'm like not really sure that makes me
feel any better so yeah um but the weird
thing about the weirdest thing about
this monologue is that palansky delivers
it as he's staring very unsettlingly at
Nancy and he has like his hand cued
under her chin like for an uncomfortably
long time so he just like has it like
that he's just like talking no one says
boo about it it's just like so [__]
strange so he then like tells the gang
he's like okay well I'm going to have
two police officers out here and they're
going to be watching the house around
the clock until we catch the murderer
right but you know probably nothing to
worry
about so here's the thing so even though
Ralph has obviously been murdered and
also a bunch of these lunkheads friends
have been missing for what like 12 hours
now at least TJ is sitting there trying
to argue oh we don't have a single thing
to be concerned about um and just gets
all over Nancy and Alex's case for well
you know you guys are worrying about
nothing and Mrs Jensen the hous mother
is also really bizarrely like unaffected
she's kind of one oh why on Earth would
anyone be frightened Nancy and Alex are
like um a dude got murdered and all our
friends are missing and she's like oh
yeah that well I'm sure everything will
work out you know what I mean she's like
all chipper going back to making the
food what and I'm just like wow this is
like so [__] weird I mean I will like
spoiler alert I will give credit like
yeah there does seem to be a reason for
that kind of later on but it's just like
in context you're just kind of like what
the [__] is happening right now you know
what I
mean um hey Leslie what's up hey uh
hello I'm late a great movie yeah hope
you're having a good Christmas Eve yeah
this is going to do we're might going to
do like another um Christmas movie
review tomorrow night but I'm not really
sure which one it'll be yet might be
Ginger dead man because we did watch
that last night but we'll see but
that'll be me and Tom this one I just
watched so after this after that point
so there's a whole bunch of kind of
repeated and sort of pointless
discussions where the various factions
of people argue about whether they're
actually in danger or not do you think
we're in danger well why why do you
think we're in danger they say in danger
like a lot and in the middle of all that
Leia one of the girls she seduces like
one of the lumpy middle-aged cops that
was sent out to protect them and bangs
him in her room while her nominal
boyfriend TJ uh gets upset about it for
about a second but then he hones in on
Melody um and her you know admittedly
larger breasts okay so there's that so
he's just like ah [__] her now the
second cop who is patrolling outside um
gets axed by the killer Santa I mean he
basically walks up to the person in the
Santa suit and is like why are you
wearing that ridiculous get up oh you
know like the Santa like had an axe over
their shoulder and the cops just like
hey what are you doing oh okay you're
axing me to death I see all right so so
there's that and then Leia after she
boinks the cop she goes to take like a
post qual shower or whatever and then
she finds Sam's severed head like stuck
upside down on the shower head you know
what I mean and I was like oh okay
that's kind of funny so maybe that porn
star thing was on purpose CU they're
like hey we're going to put the head on
the shower head and I was like all right
I see what you did there movie that was
kind of funny um so yeah so you got like
fraternizing with the witness cop also
gets stabbed in the back when he like
comes into the bathroom like cuz he
hears Leia screaming CU she saw the head
you know what I mean and he comes in and
then the Santa like stabs him in the
back and then the killer Santa like kind
of approaches naked ass Leah but then
like we cut away before we see what
happened to her right so at this point
TJ and Melody have gone outside to make
out for absolutely no reason oh it's
like we need some fresh air I'm like
open a window okay you know what I mean
I don't know so they go outside even
though specifically the cops said don't
go outside I mean both the cops are dead
but they don't know that so TJ actually
gets killed by the killer Santa who's
kind of perched on the tree branch over
them and like has like a like a wire
thing and like tries to pull his head
off or whatever now Melody gets away
while TJ is getting killed and she makes
it back to the house and then her Alex
and Nancy are kind of like tearing
through all the rooms freaking out and
then they find the dead cop and then
they find Sam's head so you know so
that's obviously really upsetting now
they also find Leia who's still alive
but it kind of looks like she's suffered
some psychotic break or something cuz it
looks like she had her makeup in
wardrobe her makeup in wardrobe um
inspired by the Linda's demon form from
the Evil Dead you know what I mean like
is that white dress and like the weird
makeup and everything it looks kind of
like that and she's kind of like dancing
around humming like a weirdo so yeah so
I guess she's had some kind of
dissociation or or something like that
so at this point you have like the final
battle between the killer Santa and the
survivors um so you got Alex and Nancy
fighting the killer in the house and
then Melody like runs off to the air
strip to wake up porn pilot to fly them
out of there right now somehow the
killer Santa is also in the cockpit of
the plane though and turns on the
propeller like right in time to like
chop up Melody and porn pilot although
at first I have to say the way it's
edited I wasn't sure if both of them got
killed because all we see like they cut
away and all we see is like a few red
chunks like hitting the plane's fuselage
you know what I mean so I was just kind
of like wait did it just get porn pilot
or did it get Melody too or whatever but
yeah I guess they're both dead but they
both just like were
chunks now back at the house the Killer
is revealed to be spoiler alert Mrs
Jensen um who it turns out is the the
mom of the girl who was accidentally
killed 2 years ago by falling over the
railing yes this movie did the mother
taking revenge for the death of her kid
thing before Friday the 13th you know so
she's like Mrs Jensen was like the Proto
Mrs Vorhees there you go now Mrs Jensen
seems particularly Keen to kill
Nancy even though Nancy says that she
only started at the school last year and
didn't even know this psycho's daughter
right Mrs Jensen says no you drugged her
which I don't know she didn't look like
she was drugged I don't know what that
had to do with anything but you know and
I guess that's meant to be a reference
to Nancy drugging Mrs Jensen's milk like
at the beginning of the movie um and it
should be noted too like when that was
happening like when they asked her
they're like will you have to spike Mrs
Jensen's milk because she you'll be the
only person she doesn't suspect um Nancy
says why do I always have to do your
dirt dir work thank you very much Aaron
merry Merry Christmas hope you have a
great day Jenny thank you very much love
the cookbook very funny reading the
descriptions yeah we just we had a lot
of fun doing that cookbook I basically
like recorded Tom talking and then like
put it into text for you know what I
mean kind of finagled it a little bit
but yeah but thank you so much I hope
you guys have a really Merry Christmas
um but yes we're getting all the getting
all the super chats today it's like rits
are really awesome happy holidays
so um so yeah so so when they were
convincing Nancy to put the drugs in the
milk she said why do I always have to do
your dirty work now this would seem to
imply that Nancy had done this
before um you know which may be what Mrs
Jensen is talking about in regards to
her daughter so I'm like so is Nancy
lying about only being at the school for
one year or is Mrs Jensen just
delusional or what I mean Mrs Jensen is
the house mother so you would think that
she would know if Nancy had been at the
school when her daughter died but on the
other hand Nancy is not portrayed as a
type of character who would lie so I'm
really just confused as to what the [__]
is going on here and I couldn't really
see you know the the scene at the
beginning where they show the girl
falling off the railing I couldn't
really see if Nancy was one of those
girls um who had been there when she
fell over the railing and to be honest
the scene happened so quick that I
didn't really recognize any of the girls
there as being the same girls that got
murdered in this movie so I'm like okay
well if that was just like a bunch of
random girls now you're just like
killing like and okay so if Mrs Jensen
was specifically taking revenge on the
girls who were responsible for the death
of her daughter which would make sense
right what why did she also kill the
guys for one thing why did she wait 2
years to do it instead of just doing it
like immediately you know what I mean um
and why did she leave Leia alive that
was another thing too so the whole thing
just kind of made no sense to me because
I'm just sitting there thinking but wait
U I don't even think any of these girls
are the same girls like they don't look
like the same girls I don't know maybe
they were and I just couldn't but like I
said it happened so quick and it was
just like a bunch of faces and a bunch
of people and you couldn't really see
and they didn't look like the same
people and I was just like that doesn't
make any sense to me at all um speaking
of making no sense there's another
second twist another reveal that takes
place a little bit after the first one
which at least explains how the killer
Santa could be at the house you know
menacing Nancy and Alex and also be in
the plane chopping up Melody and porn
pilot yes it turns out 16 years before
scream there are two killer SAS count
them two can you guess who the second
one is it's the cop
palansky who it turns out is Mrs
Jensen's husband therefore the dead
girl's father
now he also seems to be under the
impression that Nancy is the one most
responsible for his daughter's death I
don't know why and he kind of like
laments that he didn't kill her first
before he killed all the other people
you know what I mean so Mrs Jensen
eventually gets some kind of poetic
justice when Nancy kind of accidentally
on purpose sort of throws her over the
same railing where her daughter got
thrown over so I'm like it's a little
bit ice cold there Nancy but okay
um and then it looks like palansky is
going to kill Nancy but then Alex like
takes him out with the crossbow from
earlier that s used to kill one of the
others so Nancy and Alex then run away
from the house leaving Leia there like
all alone like just dancing around and
humming in her white dress or whatever
it seemed like it almost seemed like
they were trying to set up a sequel
where she was going to be the killer but
I don't know if that's the case cuz
otherwise why would why would they leave
her there you know what I mean it's like
hey we got to go back for for late nah
[__] her you know what I mean they just
kind of left she's crazy it's like we're
not taking her with it she she'll just
slow us down whatever so yeah um so it's
not a great film by any means um so I'm
going to say like most of the actors and
the characters they play are kind of
insufferable um the dialogue is just
packed with super cheesy and honestly
kind of borderline nonsensical double on
tandas um and there were also a couple
of instances
of incorrect word usage which I thought
was very strange like there was one I
wish I could remember the other one but
I know that at some point somebody used
the word staunch in a way that was not
the correct way to use that word like
they meant another word but they used
that one and I was just like somebody
needed a thesaurus or a dictionary or
something like that but I can't remember
what the other one was but the other one
and it was the nerd character that said
it he said some word and I was like
that's not the word that you wanted to
use there that's not right so yeah so
that was like very very weird so
incredible melting man who wrote the
screenplay he's got a lot to answer for
here he needs a like I said he needs a
dictionary um yeah and I like the twist
at least you figuring out that Mrs
Jensen was the first Santa I didn't
figure out that there was a second Santa
and that there and that it was palansky
but I did figure out that Mrs Jensen was
the killer probably so it was like
fairly predictable which like I said
it's a slasher most people can figure
out how they go um you know so I will
note too that the version that I watched
on shutter has clearly been cleaned up
it actually looks pretty good but I
heard when I was researching the movie
um the earlier versions of it were like
so muddy that you couldn't even see some
of the scenes so it has been like
restored but it's still not great like
the cinematography and like you know the
lighting and stuff isn't all that great
um the special effects are not that
fantastic uh especially like I said the
very very obvious dummy at the beginning
that's like falling over the railing and
there's a couple of like really
laughably obvious day for night shots
which like I said there were night shots
they did shoot some stuff at night so I
don't know why they had a couple of
shots in there that were supposed to be
nighttime but were obviously afternoon
you know what I mean it just seemed like
that seemed like a really easy thing
that you could have remedied but you
know what I mean um and I'm going to say
it is pretty apparent that this movie
was shot in 10 days on I believe a
$70,000 budget or $75,000 budget
something like that so A very very low
budget um you know and on top of that
the movie obviously takes some very
conspicuous uh cues from Black Christmas
but doesn't really have the same like
wit or intelligence or suspense or great
characterization that black Christmas
has you know what I mean um and I'm
going to say oh and this isn't the
filmmaker's fault but the original
poster art which is what I put on the
thumbnail is kind of lame um it and it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the movie it's not christmy at all and I
don't really know if they designed it
afterward because they knew it was
wasn't coming out at Christmas time um
it looks like from the poster that the
characters are going to be menaced by
something paranormal you know what I
mean like a bigheaded alien or like a
demon or something like that because
that's what the poster looks like it
doesn't have any Christmas cues on it I
mean this is a killer Santa movie
there's two killer Santa it's Santa
there's it's not paranormal or nothing
it's just like slasher movie and it's a
Santa killer so I don't know why they
didn't the the poster isn't Christmasy
at all like I said that's not the
filmmaker thing cuz that's usually like
another department that does that kind
of stuff all that said though this is
still a pretty fun um holiday slasher
it's just a very serviceable like you
know what I mean it's just kind of I've
seen worse slashers I've seen obviously
like way better ones this one's just
kind of on the on the low to middling
end you know what I mean um it's not all
that Bloody like I there's not a lot of
a Gore or anything like that it does
have a high body count though I think 15
people get killed in this which is which
is quite good for a slasher uh does have
some nudity if you're into that not a
[__] ton but it does have
some and I'm going to say that some of
the stuff that happens in it is like so
baffling that it sort of becomes
entertaining in spite of itself because
you're sitting there going well that was
a choice you're just like wondering like
why that happened you know what I mean
um I so so I'm going to say like it's
not some big like hidden holiday Jam or
something like that but but you know if
you happen to be in the mood for some
good old-fashioned 80s Christmas
slashing um you know there's worst ones
out there this one's pretty good and
like I said it does have some
interesting trivia about it that you
know kind of distinguishes it some um I
would recommend though getting good and
drunk first and maybe like msing the
[__] out of it like for maximum
enjoyment because that's kind of I
wasn't drunk when I watched it but I was
riffing on it the whole time and like
and that does like make it a lot better
because some of the stuff in there like
some of the stuff the characters say and
like some of the way that they act and
stuff like that I'm like why what is
happening right now it's just like it's
just was so weird but it's like yeah so
like I said I think Danny recommended
this so thank you very much for the
recommendation I probably would have got
around to this eventually but you know
it's good that I kind of got to it now
because I was kind of curious to see it
because I really like David hes like as
an actor and I had heard that he had
directed a movie but I had never seen it
before but yeah so like I said it's not
great but it's still like pretty fun you
know what I mean um um yeah Danny said
this film's super underrated for a
Christmas flick yeah it's one that
doesn't really um get a lot of attention
and like I said I didn't love it but
I've seen like way worse ones you know
what I mean and I and I was interested
to see it because of David Hess cuz I
really really like him but yeah so
hopefully you guys have a good rest of
your Christmas Eve and have a good
Christmas morning tomorrow um like I
said me and Tom are probably going to do
a Christmas movie review tomorrow night
at 7:30 like we normally would I'm not
sure which movie it might be Ginger dead
man cuz we did watch that last night so
we might talk about that or I don't know
or we might watch something else tonight
we'll see how it goes um because there's
still a lot of Christmas horror that we
haven't seen yet so but yeah so have a
good holiday you guys thanks for
dropping by today and listening me talk
about some Christmas horror movies and
thank you for your super chats and I
will see you guys again tomorrow night
Merry Christmas